il signe de l'urgence de la situation
washington et moscou ont tenu un point
de presse en fin de journée avec les
choses se bousculent
on veut éviter une escalade une perte de
contrôle de la situation
oui c'est lui parce que l'attention est
vraiment monté d'un cran de façon très
sérieuse aujourd'hui vous savez ça fait
quand même des mois que les américains
et leurs alliés pylône est quasiment
quotidiennement les positions de l'état
islamique et là on à moscou qui débarque
ifrap mais qui apparemment tir dans
l'autre sens parce que selon le
pentagone
c'était pas du tout les positions d'état
islamique que visait moscou mais bien
les en fait les rebelles qui s'opposent
au régime de hassan alors évidemment un
sergueï lavrov le ministère le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères
aujourd'hui a démenti formellement la
chose sauf que c'est un peu difficile et
peu crédible de plaider l'ignorance puis
de dire qu'on s'est trompé de cible
alors l'urgence est là et donc résultat
aussitôt que demain les militaires
américains et russes vont se parler pour
essayer de sortir de l'impasse parce que
la situation est urgente ont pu écouter
là-dessus john kerry a délibérément le
disert son reportage moscou a toujours
soutenu le régime la famille al assad il
ya plus que ça c'est moscou veut
défendre ses intérêts son influence dans
cette région qui est stratégie c'est
clair ces lignes on sait que monsieur
poutine ne veut pas rester dans les
gradins regarder ce qui se passe il veut
être un acteur de premier plan
il vient un peu brouillé les cartes
évidemment mais il aime le faire aussi
dans d'autres dossiers par exemple dans
l'iran parce que pour lui c'est une
occasion en or de finalement se poser en
contrepoids politique important face à
l'affluence des américains le problème
c'est que ça se fait dans un terrain
miné celui de la série et pendant ce
temps là bas l'état et cela mais
continue d'étendre son pouvoir et de
commettre des massacres horribles alors
demain la réunion est importante mais ne
vous attendez pas à voir moscou et
washington marché de main dans la main
pour résoudre ce dossier là très
rapidement la guerre qui a déjà fait
deux cent cinquante mille morts des
millions de déplacés
dans un tout nouveau réfugiés bien sûr
en europe merci beaucoup ferez vous en
prie